hey this is a really interesting story
um there is a new report
cnn and others reporting that ivanka
trump
and jared kushner are now distanced
and maybe even estranged from former
president donald trump because of his
complete inability to move on
from having lost the 2020 election cnn
reports with each passing day away from
washington former
president trump's grievances continue
unabated and those complaints appear to
be driving away two of the people who
were closest to him during his white
house tenure his daughter ivanka trump
and his son-in-law jared kushner
going on to say a large part of the
reason for the separation
is trump's constant harping on the past
and his inability to move on the former
president has also started to question
the role that kushner one of the few
people
who were able to stay close to trump
throughout his two presidential
campaigns in white house tenure
has played in his presidential legacy
ivanka trump has also struggled to undo
the entanglements caused by the years at
her father's side in the white house
as she seeks a less complicated life for
her family
according to two acquaintances that
seems like a reference to the complete
disaster that was ivanka and jared
trying to reintegrate themselves into
new york city
life and being shunned they described
her as having to walk a fine line
between embracing her father
and distancing herself from the election
lies
one club-goer at mar-a-lago and family
friends said they weren't around
for the usual spring and summer events
at mar-a-lago noting the absence of
trump's elder daughter
and the couple's three young children
simultaneously the disappearance of
kushner once the ringleader of trump's
policy
was also apparent a person familiar with
kushner
says there were visits from the kushner
trump family to mar-a-lago
long before before trump's move north
but they were sparse
averaging one every three to four weeks
the physical distance between them was
not far
because kushner and ivanka were living
in miami
awaiting the construction of their
mansion on a nearby
private island kushner's presence
physically and virtually has become
increasingly rare
as it became clear that his
father-in-law remained preoccupied with
the 2020 election
according to one person familiar with
the situation
um this is not hugely surprising to me
you know uh it became clear in the late
days of the trump administration that
in particular jared and ivanka and
especially ivanka
were realizing that the reintegration
was not going to go
super smoothly there were reports about
their they're being shunned by the high
society circles in which they previously
ran
and this is not i don't feel bad for
them i don't care they chose this
um you know tiffany trump for example
stayed out of the limelight
and i'm aware of her having many
left-wing friends and she sort of goes
in
in different circles and is not being
shunned in the same way although her
role at the republican national
convention was pretty disgusting
uh don jr and eric are fully bought in
to continuing the sycophantic brown
nosing you see them regularly on fox
news
and newsmax and on other programs so
they've they've
kind of staked out that position in the
aftermath of the trump administration
ivanka and jared and in particular
ivanka have removed themselves from
politics
but they were so visible and so involved
during this administration
that now people are saying we don't we
don't like you you know before we
accepted you
and you were less overtly political and
at least you weren't
actively going around as republicans
remember trump was a democrat much of
his life
so whether we liked you or not they were
kind of tolerated in these high society
circles in manhattan and
and los angeles miami etcetera but
they're they're they're now in a sense
uh tainted
but and kushner just disastrous
participation remember they're our it's
our stockpile it's not their stockpile
that entire thing um he's doing masks
he's doing schwabs and all of this stuff
it's become so humiliating and so
embarrassing that now
they are having trouble reintegrating
into society that's their choice
but the estrangement from donald trump
is very interesting and the political
connection is
is a very narrow one which
we'll mention briefly uh
one question about trump 2024 is what
will trump's health be like then
second question about trump 2024 is will
he still have the bulk of the republican
party behind him
third question about 2024 is will
trump's
favorites win in 22 and if they don't
does that hurt his chances
but there's another question here which
is if there is a trump 2024 run
does he have the same coalition of his
family strongly supporting him because
for not not all but for many of these
right-wingers particularly the
evangelicals
they had to be li well they most they
all were lied to but the evangelical
specifically had to be lied to about oh
trump's pro-life now he's been
pro-choice his whole life
suddenly six months before running for
president he's
pro-life the evangelicals had to be sold
that bill of goods
and similarly trump has a family man
with his children all around him
even though the cheating the divorce you
know all this different stuff it doesn't
matter they were able to ignore it
but the the family unit around trump was
a big piece
uh for some of those evangelicals along
with the lies about abortion and other
things
in them ultimately coming around to him
without that does trump have the same
cachet for some of these religious
rightists if the family
is not around him i don't know the
answer to that question but it's
something we will know
before too long one of our sponsors is
curiosity stream giving my audience 25
off i love documentaries if you love
them you really have to have
curiosity stream the streaming service
offering
thousands of documentaries from some of
the world's best filmmakers
it's like netflix but just for
documentaries
i've been watching it non-stop curiosity
stream has an
app for your tv phone tablet roku
game console i recently watched the
secret lives of
sharks fascinating stuff i've noticed
curiosity stream always has the biggest
and newest documentary titles including
stuff you will not find on other
streaming services they're regularly
adding new documentaries to the lineup
you're not going to run out of good
stuff to watch when you go to
curiositystream
pacman you'll get unlimited access to
the world's top documentaries
just for my viewers when you use the
promo code pacman
you will get 25 off a subscription which
comes out to only
14 14.99 per year